I don't know if you know this or not but
a lot of inflation is out there these
days came out and said six percent this
year year over year six percent
inflation so your bank account
lost six percent of its purchasing power
let's break down what that means so
money as they say is a tool it's just a
tool or a financial instrument to get
what you want it doesn't actually have
value it's the value you can get from it
right it's based on what the money can
buy it's a medium of exchange yeah so
that money went down six percent you can
buy six percent less stuff so
if you have a bank account and you've
got let's just like take some actual
examples here in your bank account
you've got 10 grand you think cool I'm
chilling on 10 grand right there that's
only purchasing power of 9 400 if you've
got a hundred grand in the bank what's
up baby you're that dude Jose found 100
Grand he's got a bag 100 Grand
purchasing power 94 and then it went
down when he called the cops and then it
went down big time when he called the
cops so inflation is real six percent
you know what's going on obviously I'm
all about save that money save that
money save that money save that money
get to a cushion where you're
comfortable and then invest I say this
all the time ninety percent of my wealth
Mr save that money guy is in the market
is in finances is Investments I'm
getting that compound interest
let that thing grow and some of the
reasons why you know obviously after you
have a cushion where can you put the
money now savings accounts pay zero zero
I mean the point with basis points we
talked about
0.0012.004 oh we got a new savings
account we're giving you 0.03 now okay
great it's paying next to nothing right
bonds old people got bonds rich people
got bonds if you're looking to grow your
money bonds ain't the play treasury
bills government bonds T bills paying
like one and a half percent next to
nothing traditionally gold which is a
good
um
what's the word hedge hedge against
inflation that's actually been flat the
past year but the stock market baby it's
been up over 10 for the last decade this
year to date 16 we talked about this
before and Bitcoin and crypto to the
Moon
so
the goal is to have enough money in cash
that you can move from being in debt to
being a saver to be an investor red
light yellow light green light red light
is that right yellow light saving green
light invested to the Moon you know what
is the great Warren Buffett's Buffett
said about being inflation proof he says
be the best at what you are be the
absolute best whether you're a producer
whether you're a dentist whether you're
a teacher whether you're a politician
whatever it is
being inflation proof is being the best
at what you do he says the best
investment is in yourself so if you guys
are listening out there and you're
getting out of debt and you're saving
that money you're on the right track
you've done two out of three now it's
time to invest baby
so
that's that quick thoughts on that David
before we move on six percent
it's it's obviously pbd did a video on
the city released it's on YouTube but
yeah it's it's scary it's something that
um you don't want to see especially I
mean you're not surprised coming out of
a pandemic kind of seeing this but it's
also not all the money printing all the
money all the stimis that are out there
scary I wish I had like uh you know more
knowledge to give a better
opinion but it's just it's obviously
something I don't want to see and I
don't want to see again yeah but I'm
sure it will Marcelo I know you're
working hard to get to the 10 grand
level not to put your business on the
street you're getting close but what
happens if you were to find out that
your 10 grand is actually only 9 400. I
wouldn't care
all right
no um
no honestly I think that um I have a
much I have a long-term plan like I'm
not thinking about inflation at all
right now I'm in a place in my business
where all I'm thinking about is getting
more work and getting my product better
and making my business AKA being the
best at what you do yeah I'm just trying
to become the best at what I do I don't
care about inflation I don't care about
Investments I don't care about the stock
market I'm trying to become the best
comedic personality baby let me tell you
something there's a part of me that's
like oh this kid I don't know about
inflation but there's a part of me that
actually agrees with you right we can't
control the freaking inflation it is
what it is right yeah you know we talk
about it we'd spend an hour on it on pbd
podcast I'm thinking guys
it is what it is what are we going to do
about it you can control what you can
control right I mean Danielle Danielle
di Martino Booth is an economist she can
maybe actually control some of this
stuff I don't know what you can do but
like your perspective there's not a lot
you can do to control inflation save
that money get out of debt invest that
money talk is money all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
saucecast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
friends